uh the 49ers have some new dynamics that
will factor into their late season
playoff run they are in arizona for
practice this week in advance of a
monday night game chris against the
buffalo bills let's hear from kyle
shanahan coach of the 49ers regarding
this unexpected but not completely
not completely unforeseen development
where they can't play their games at
home and have to go to arizona
basically we're moving out there and our
hotel will be our new levi's stadium
which is where we go to work um
and just like when we're here you go to
work every day you get tested um you
know when we're here then we go straight
home to our house and stay there till
you come back the next day to work now
or i look at it as our house happens to
be where our work's at um so when we're
done with work guys just go upstairs to
their hotel room um we can't sit there
you don't want to hang out and stuff
that's that's how things people get in
trouble
and that's how it spreads that's what
happened to us during our bye week at a
hotel so we won't sit there and hang out
at all so we'll work there and then the
guys will go to their hotel room it's
often said that that guys can bond when
they're kind of in that that same spot
um honestly no none at all um
we're not allowed to bond in those spots
that's what guys did for 30 minutes
after dinner um after the new orleans
game and that's what got us a couple
positive tests
um
during our bye week so we don't have
tables out where they can eat so people
don't hang out i mean the place that we
bond is really on the field or in zoom
meetings
yeah this isn't bonding this isn't about
bonding but here's what it's about and i
guarantee you even though this is a
hardship for the individual players for
the individual coaches for everybody
else on that staff that has to leave
home
for up to five weeks if the 49ers have
to play in arizona the rest of the
season
there are coaches
out there and maybe kyle would admit
this in a quiet private moment yes but i
guarantee you there are other coaches
that are jealous
of what kyle shanahan now has he has a
bubble yeah right he has his gut right
because
kyle glossed over the idea well you know
at home they just go home and they stay
home how do you know they go home and
they stay home how do you know that they
aren't being exposed when they go home
and they're around other family members
this is the thing that coaches have been
worried about all year long once those
players and everyone else leave the
facility out into a community where the
virus is running rampant you worry that
you're going to get guys who show up
positive
that worry that stress that anxiety is
now plummeted if everyone is in the
hotel the hotel is levi's stadium as
kyle said that this is
not quite discovering plutonium by
accident because we've known it's been
there all year this is circumstances
giving the 49ers what most coaches would
want
a local bubble where you don't have to
worry about your guys when they go home
at night well it could be to what you're
saying you're going down a playoff run
like this there's no room for error
right now with the 49ers to wear yeah it
could be kind of a a blessing in
disguise i hear you there i do um but
man i mean i just think about first off
the 49ers in totality their year wow i
mean yeah covid super bowl loss all that
i mean record-breaking injuries we've
never seen a team really especially a
defending super bowl champion have to
deal with the amount of injuries the
49ers have the star players that they've
missed
now
you deal with this too you know and
there's just this ongoing feud between
the 49ers and the city of santa clara
and issues there and to have to go there
and yeah to like what you're saying it's
a good thing as far as the bubble
mentality and you don't have to worry
about that but wow what a whirlwind just
for players and coaches and everything
to just be on the road again you know oh
hey you know meetings everything like
that is going to be a little awkward
coaches where do i watch my film where
do we break this down how does this all
work i mean that's just some curveball
some wrench to throw into an
organization you know i know kyle can
handle it i'm not worried about that
but uh just the the 49ers i'm amazed of
all the things and obstacles they've had
to overcome this year
and i watched the 49ers rand's game back
yesterday we we made that the subject of
our pftpm weekly rewatch yeah
the the 49ers even with everything
they've been through even with all those
key players gone they are still a
quality team they are to go into la and
complete the sweep of a rams team that
that knew it couldn't afford to be swept
by a team in its own division now they
have to worry about the 49ers
potentially catching them leapfrogging
them the 49ers just two games behind but
they hold that tiebreaker edge with the
rams that was a huge huge win and and
i've got even more respect for your guy
kyle uh for his ability to and it's that
belichick you know i keep comparing him
to belgium in a good way not the gruff
you know gratuitous guy that rolls his
eyes and harumps when he's asked a
question that he doesn't like but
the next man up and the no excuses no
excuses we expect whoever comes in to
replace the guy that's injured or is on
the covet 19 reserve list to play at the
level that that
we
expect for the starter yeah right and
right you know again it's it's still
not putting them in the category of in
the playoffs but they're in the hunt and
they could be as dangerous from the back
of the pack as they were from the front
of the pack because they're to me the
nfc's equivalent of the patriots if they
get in you don't want them showing up in
your building in january yeah no it's
it's they're still like you said too
many big physical guys up front you know
they're still a good looking football
team and then even with those guys that
you're talking about that are not
starters that are the backups everything
you know the one thing
you know that coaching staff does is
they give their players a little bit of
a schematical advantage always too i
mean kyle's amazing at finding ways for
the offense to get off and make plays no
matter who's the quarterback or whatever
it is and now he's got iuke and debo
samuel both healthy and he had no george
kittle but it's enough of him to play
with between moztert wilson some of the
running backs they have and he does a
great job of making the game easy for
guys making it fun and then putting them
in positions that are meant for them to
succeed and then robert saul is the same
way on the defensive side of the ball
you know robert salah i know he was this
big head coaching candidate last year
because why they were a super bowl team
he should still be one this year he's
doing another
job it should he's a damn good coach he
really is he's creative as hell his team
always plays hard and uh that's what's
impressive about them it really is and
it goes into something you and i have
talked to too the kind of player they've
drafted and signed in free agency there
where it's just wait it's my turn coach
said run through the wall okay i'm gonna
run through the wall there's no
hesitation let's go we saw the
psychoness of that team at the playoff
game last year remember i think you and
i and rodney were all taken back like
whoa they got a lot of psychos out here
whoa they're overconfident and whoa they
don't give a damn and it's that's what
lynch and shanahan have done to that
organization
yeah and that's a key and i think that
needs to be amplified we noticed that
last year at a time when you have
limited contact limited padded practices
limited if any tackling to the ground in
practice you need guys who can flip the
switch and go be badasses yeah and and
not have to practice tackling you don't
you know for certain guys you don't need
to practice what you innately know how
to do and that's what they have one
quick point before we move on yeah
because this kind of dawned on shireen
and i last night as we were talking
about both the seahawks and the 49ers on
pftpm
they have debo samuel in san francisco
and he was awesome this week after
missing five weeks he came back and
didn't miss a beat right he was great he
was the best player on the field
yep
if dk metcalf had just dropped a few
more spots
they could have had him they took jalen
hurd the baylor receiver who's never
played because of injury yeah and i just
would love to know i'd love to know you
need to get kyle drunk one night and ask
him if metcalf had been there if the
seahawks hadn't taken it was just three
spots later when the 49ers drafted and
they drafted another receiver could you
imagine debo samuel and dk metcalf on
that team now i i don't know that
metcalf would have the opportunities
that he's had in seattle to become who
he's become yeah but could you imagine
those two guys on the field i can i can
and i i feel pretty confident in saying
that if dk metcalf was there for that
pick that kyle would have taken him yeah
i i know
kyle might not like me saying this or
whatever he really liked dk metcap he
liked debo samuel a little bit more
obviously i think he felt like he fit
his offense and a little bit with the
speed sweep stuff and that was it but he
was very pro dk metcalf i'd have a hard
time thinking he would have passed them
up if he was on the board again and wait
one last thing too mike i know they're
playing their games there
are they are they staying there all week
through the next few weeks too that's
right i'm just a little confused with
some of the comments sounds like they
are they are right like they are okay
okay because a few times you said levi's
stadium hotel and i was just like what
no okay
no kyle said our hotel is basically
levi's stadium yeah that that's where
we're going to be and that's where we're
going to stay so they're staying there
and apparently the families have option
to come out and join them i don't know
how all that's going to work and again
you're introducing individuals into your
mini bubble that could be problematic or
i think what could happen is the
families could set up at an airbnb or
something like that
and then and then it is the same deal
you go home you can come here you said
levi and it's state farm right the other
stadium that's where i think that's the
other day so sorry sorry about that i'm
blonde and i'm football sorry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports